>> And so now let's give the explanation for the quiz.
>> Alright, so, let's see what happened here. So,
what you're saying is in some cases the inputs are
discrete or continuous or complicated. In other cases the outputs
could be discrete or continuous or complicated. But I think
what you were saying is, that what on, on,
what matters to determine if something is classification or regression
is whether the output is from a discrete small set
or, or whether it's some continuous quantity. Is that right?
>> Right, that's exactly right. The difference between
a classification task or a regression task is
not about the input, it's about the output.
If the output is continuous then it's regression
and if the output is small discrete set
or discrete set, then it is a classification
task. So, with that in mind, what do you think is the answer to the first one?
>> So, lend money. If it was something like predicting
a credit score, that seems like a more continuous quantity.
But this is just a yes no, so that's
a discrete class, so I'm going to go with classification.
>> That is, correct. It is classification and the short answer is, because
it's a binary task. True, false. Yes, no. Lend money or don't lend money.
>> Got it.
>> So it's a simple classification test. Okay,
with that in mind, what about number two?
>> Alright, so number two. It's trying to judge
something about where they fall on a scale, high school,
college, or grad student. But all of, the system is being asked to do is put
them into one of those three categories, and
these categories are like classes, so it's classification.
>> That is also exactly right. Classification. We moved from binary
to trinary in this case, but the important thing is that it's
discrete. So it doesn't matter if it's high school, college grad,
professor, elementary school, any number of other ways we might decide where
your status of matriculation is is a small discrete
set. So, with that in mind, what about number three?
>> Alright, so the input is the same in this case. And the output is kind of
the same except there's, well there's certainly more
categories because there's more possible ages than just those
three. But when you gave the example you
did explicitly say that ages can be fractional like,
you know, 22.3. So that definitely makes me
think that it's continuous, so it should be regression.
>> Right, I think that is exactly the
right thing, you have a continuous output. Now,
I do want to point something out. That
while the right answer is regression, a lot of
people might have decided that the answer was
classification. So, what's an argument? If I told
you in fact the answer was classification, what
would be your argument for why that would be?
>> Well, I guess.
>> Can you think of one?
>> Yeah, I guess. I mean, you know,
if you think about ages as being discrete. You
just say, you know, you can one or two or three or, you know, whatever up to
130, say. But there, but there's just that, that
set. There isn't really, you know, usually we don't talk
about fractional ages. So, so it seems like you could
think of it as, as, as a set of classes.
>> Right. So let's imagine. So, how
old are people? Let's imagine we only cared
about years, so you're either one or two or three or four or five. Or maybe
you can be one and a half, and two and a half, and three and a
half. But, whatever, it's, it's not all possible
real number values. And we know that people
don't live beyond, say, 250. Well, in that case, you've got a very large
discrete set but it's still discrete. Doesn't matter whether there's two things
in your set, three things in your set, or in this case 250 things in
your set, it's still discrete. So, whether it's regression, or classification,
depends upon exactly how you define your output and these things
become important. I'm going to argue that in practice, if you were
going to set up this problem, the easiest way to do it
would be to think about it as a real number and
you would predict something like 23.7. And so it's going to end
up being a regression task and we can might, maybe think
about that a little bit more as we move along. So
either answer would be acceptable depending
upon what your explanation of exactly
what the output was. Was. You buy that?
>> That makes sense.
>> Excellent. Okay. Alright, let's move beyond the
quiz and start thinking about exactly what it
means to define a classification problem. And then
later what it means to define a regression problem.